It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
正是授粉高峰期，我的业务规模迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然保持稳定。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这真是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需另付税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Would you eat meat grown in a lab? The U.S. Food and Drug Administration and the Department of Agriculture have given the go-ahead for cultured meat to be sold in the U.S., although it's not yet available in stores. Advocates of cultured meat say that it could help address the environmental and animal welfare concerns that come with meeting the public's desire for chicken, burgers, and steak. But not everyone is convinced. In March, Mississippi became the third state to outlaw the sale of cultured meat, joining Florida
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷期间不会降低数据传输优先级。你会吃实验室培养的肉吗？美国食品药品监督管理局和农业部已批准在美国销售培植肉，尽管它尚未在商店上架。培植肉的倡导者表示，这有助于解决满足公众对鸡肉、汉堡和牛排的需求所带来的环境和动物福利问题。但并非所有人都深信不疑。三月份，密西西比州成为继佛罗里达州之后
and Alabama. And beyond the legal threats, researchers have found that a significant portion of consumers say they would just be reluctant to try it. Today we're going to talk to two psychologists about why that is. What are the psychological factors at play when people consider eating lab-grown meat or meat in general? How do moral values, disgust, and other psychological factors contribute to people's dietary choices? And could lab-grown meat become a viable part of most consumers diet in the future. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
和阿拉巴马州之后，第三个立法禁止销售培植肉的州。除了法律层面的威胁，研究人员还发现，相当一部分消费者表示他们只是对尝试这种肉心存抗拒。今天，我们将采访两位心理学家，探讨这背后的原因。当人们考虑吃实验室培养的肉或肉类本身时，究竟有哪些心理因素在起作用？道德价值观、厌恶感和其他心理因素如何影响人们的饮食选择？实验室培养的肉未来能否成为大多数消费者饮食中切实可行的一部分？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. I have two guests today. First is Dr. Maddie Wilkes, a lecturer in psychology at the University of Edinburgh. She has studied people's attitudes toward cultured meat and what's called the Natural is Better bias. More broadly, she's interested in people's moral motivation. and choices, including children's moral development, people's concern for animals, and unusually altruistic people. Dr. Wilk's work has been covered by Scientific American, New Scientists, and
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我有两位嘉宾。首先是爱丁堡大学心理学讲师麦迪·威尔克斯（Maddie Wilkes）博士。她研究过人们对培植肉的态度以及所谓的“天然更好”偏误。更广泛地说，她对人们的道德动机和选择感兴趣，包括儿童的道德发展、人们对动物的关爱以及异常利他的人。威尔克斯博士的研究已被《科学美国人》、《新科学家》和其他
other publications. Also with us today is Dr. Daniel Rosenfeld, a postdoctoral scholar at the University of California, Los Angeles. This research centers on eating behavior with a particular focus on the psychology of vegetarianism, as well as attitudes toward cultured meat. He's published dozens of scientific articles and his work has been covered by media outlets, including NPR, the Wall Street Journal, and WebMD. Dr. Wilkes, Dr. Rosenfeld, thank you for joining me today. Thank you very much for having me. Happy to be here.
等出版物报道。今天与我们同行的还有加利福尼亚大学洛杉矶分校的博士后学者丹尼尔·罗森菲尔德（Daniel Rosenfeld）博士。他的研究中心是饮食行为，特别关注素食主义心理学以及对培植肉的态度。他发表了数十篇科学文章，其研究成果已被 NPR、《华尔街日报》和 WebMD 等媒体报道。威尔克斯博士、罗森菲尔德博士，非常感谢你们今天能来参加节目。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。
Let's start by explaining what cultured meat is. How is it different from conventional meat and plant-based meat substitutes? So conventional meat is the most prototypical kind of meat when you think about meat. That's when you raise an animal and at a certain point you slaughter it and you consume its flesh as meat. Plant-based meats are using plants, so that could be vegetables or beans or lentils or grains or tofu, and essentially creating a product that mirrors the taste and texture of meat to some degree and is used. using plants to create a meat-like product or a meat analog. And that's a typical veggie burger or something like the impossible burger or Beyond burger.
让我们从解释什么是培植肉开始。它与传统肉类和植物性肉类替代品有何不同？传统肉类是当你想到肉时最典型的肉。那是当你饲养一只动物，在某个时候屠宰它，并将其肉作为肉食用。植物性肉类使用的是植物，可以是蔬菜、豆类、扁豆、谷物或豆腐，本质上是创造一种在某种程度上模仿肉类口感和质地的产品，并用于利用植物制造类似肉类的产品或肉类替代品。这就是典型的素食汉堡，或者像不可能汉堡（Impossible Burger）或超越汉堡（Beyond Burger）之类的产品。
Then cultured meat or cultivated meat is its own category. It's different than the other two where you're taking a part of an animal cell. So say a biopsy from an animal, a living animal, and you grow the animal cells. or tissues into a more advanced form of what that cell could grow into. So you create meat from that cell. You make the cell grow and grow and grow until it is a literal animal tissue there that mirrors real animal flesh. So you're creating quote unquote real meat, meat that is, from an animal,
然后，培植肉或培养肉属于它自己的类别。它与其他两类不同，你需要取动物细胞的一部分。比如活体动物的活检，然后将动物细胞或组织培育成该细胞可以生长的更高级形式。因此，你用该细胞创造肉。你让细胞不断生长，直到它成为真正的动物组织，模仿真正的动物肌肉。所以你创造的是所谓的真正的肉，即来自动物的肉，
from a sampling of the animal's tissue rather than slaughtering the entire animal to get that meat from them. Not to get too deep into the weeds here, but does it matter from which part of the animal you take the cells? So if you're looking for filet mignon or a rump steak, does it matter where in the animal you take the cells from? So to my understanding, all cultured meat is primarily developed through stem cells. But I couldn't tell you about the specifics of whether, yeah, whether you need certain elements of that to create certain parts of certain kinds of meat. That's a really interesting question. To establish your bona fides, I would like to know for certain.
通过对动物组织的采样，而不是屠宰整只动物来获取这些肉。话虽如此，我们不必过于深入探讨细节，但从动物的哪个部位提取细胞重要吗？所以如果你在寻找菲力牛排或臀肉牛排，你在动物的哪个部位提取细胞重要吗？据我所知，所有的培植肉主要都是通过干细胞开发的。但我无法告诉你关于是否、是的，是否需要某些特定元素来创造特定种类肉的某些部分的具体细节。这是一个非常有趣的问题。为了确立你的专业权威，我很想确切知道。
You have both eaten cultured meat, right? I have not. I really want to, and it's not been available to me yet. It's, yeah, very sad. And I have a different answer to that. I have not eaten cultured meat. And if it were available to me, I personally would not eat it. but I hope that other people do.
你们两个都吃过培植肉，对吧？我没有。我真的很想吃，但它目前对我来说还买不到。这，是的，非常遗憾。我有一个不同的答案。我没有吃过培植肉。如果能买到，我个人也不会吃，但我希望其他人去吃。
That's interesting. So I guess it's hard for you to answer the question then as to whether it tastes like conventionally produced meat. Does it look like it? I mean, I'm sure you've seen images. Yeah, from what I've seen, you know, which is mostly on media and online because you haven't seen it in real life or I would have tried it. Yeah, it seems exactly the same. It tends to be at the moment sort of chicken nuggets and more processed type meat products rather than things like steaks, although there are some companies that will produce, for example, a cultured steak.
这很有趣。所以我想你很难回答它尝起来是否像传统生产的肉这个问题了。它看起来像吗？我的意思是，我确信你见过图片。是的，从我看到的来看，你知道，这主要在媒体和网上，因为你在现实中没见过，否则我早就尝过了。是的，它看起来一模一样。目前它往往是鸡块和加工程度更高的肉类产品，而不是像牛排之类的东西，尽管有些公司会生产例如培养牛排。
But yeah, it looks the same to me. I've spoken to people who have tried it, and they've said, you know, it tastes the same to them. Dr. Rosenfeld? Yes, from what I have read online and heard talking to people, it seems that it really mirrors the taste and texture of conventional meat very well. And as Dr. Wolf said, I know that there are differences in the kinds of meat that are easier versus harder to make and are available. So more ground-up meat like chicken nuggets or perhaps ground beef seem to be more feasible,
但是，是的，在我看来它长得一样。我跟尝过的人聊过，他们说，你知道，尝起来是一样的。罗森菲尔德博士？是的，根据我在网上读到的和与人们交谈听到的，它似乎真的很好地模仿了传统肉类的味道和质地。正如沃尔夫（Wolf）博士所说，我知道在更容易制作与更难制作以及可买到的肉类种类之间存在差异。因此，更多搅碎的肉类，如鸡块或碎牛肉，似乎更可行，
whereas things like steak just have really complex tissues and mirroring an actual bone and how the fibrous meat attaches to the bone and has the marvellized fat. And it's just a more complex thing to make. So that would be a little later on into the mass market. Now, you've both done research on consumers' attitudes toward cultured meat. broadly, what have you found? Do many consumers say that they'd be willing to try it, or is there a lot of hesitation? The first study I conducted on cultured meat, which was a long, long time ago, we got around 65% of the samples, about about two-thirds of the sample saying that they would try cultured meat, but then about a third saying that they would eat it regularly. So there was, like, enthusiasm, people were interested, but people kind of felt a bit reluctant to commit more heavily. Now, my work is roughly replicated.
而像牛排这样的东西只有非常复杂的组织，要模仿真正的骨头以及纤维状肉如何附着在骨头上并带有大理石纹脂肪，这要复杂得多。制作起来更加复杂。所以这要到稍后才能进入大众市场。现在，你们两个都做过关于消费者对培植肉态度的研究。总的来说，你们发现了什么？很多消费者表示他们愿意尝试吗，还是有很多犹豫？我进行的第一项关于培植肉的研究是很久很久以前的事了，我们大约有 65% 的样本，大约三分之二的样本说他们会尝试培植肉，但大约三分之三的人说他们会经常吃。所以当时是有热情的，人们很感兴趣，但人们对做出更坚定的承诺有点犹豫。现在，我的研究大致重复了
that and I'm pretty sure that's roughly on track with what other people find. But I know Daniel recently published a big TICS paper kind of looking at the psychology of cultured meat, or a transing cognitive science paper looking at the psychology of cultured meat. And I don't know, is that what kind of came out in your review, Daniel? Yeah, it seems that the majority of people are at least interested in trying cultured meat. And as Maddie just referenced there, there's a difference between being willing to try it versus intending to me. make it a regular staple of your diet. So a lot of people would say something like, I'm open to trying it, tasting it, but probably after that, they'll just maybe go back to eating their regular
这一点，而且我很确信这与其他人发现的结果大致吻合。但我知道丹尼尔最近发表了一篇关于培植肉心理学的大型 TICS 论文，或者说是认知科学趋势期刊（Trends in Cognitive Science）上关于培植肉心理学的论文。我不知道，丹尼尔，你的综述里是不是也得出了这种结论？是的，看起来大多数人至少对尝试培植肉感兴趣。正如麦迪刚才提到的，愿意尝试与打算将其作为日常主食之间存在区别。所以很多人会说类似这样的话：我愿意尝试、品尝它，但可能在那之后，他们就会恢复吃普通
conventional meat, whereas other people might say, I do want to try it, and I do want to adopt it into my diet and replace conventional meat with it. That seems to be, I would sense a more split of an even split of people who are willing to really go full on, adopt it versus just taste it as a sort of novelty product. So there are different motivations why somebody might want to just try it. And I believe there is word showing that people who seek novelty are open to new experiences and really enjoy being a foodie might want to try culture meat because it's an exciting, new, innovative, cool product, just like eating at the new restaurant down the street. Other people have different motivations wanting to try it. People who appreciate the value of it as
传统肉类，而其他人可能会说，我确实想尝试，我也确实想把它融入我的饮食中，用它取代传统肉类。这似乎是，我感觉愿意真正全力以赴、接受它的人与只是把它当作一种新奇产品来品尝的人之间的一种更均匀的对半分。所以，一个人想要尝试的原因可能各有不同。我相信有证据表明，寻求新鲜感、对新体验持开放态度并且真正喜欢成为美食家的人可能想要尝试培植肉，因为这是一种令人兴奋、新颖、创新、酷炫的产品，就像去街角的那家新餐厅吃饭一样。其他人想要尝试的动机则不同。那些欣赏其价值的人，认为它是一种
being something that could reduce animal suffering or help the environment, they're the ones who are more willing to say integrate it into their diet longer term. We also find just very briefly, like there are a group of, there also tend to be a small sample or small subset of samples that feel very negatively towards it as well. So I have research, for example, where we find that, you know, 20% or so of some samples will say things like cultured meat would be wrong no matter how small the risk and how great the benefit. So it's this very strong, absolute, almost, moral opposition to cultured meat as well, which tends to be much smaller portion of the population, but not nobody.
能够减少动物痛苦或有助于环境的事物，他们更愿意说在长期饮食中将其整合进来。我们还发现，简而言之，有一小群人，样本中也往往存在一小部分对它感觉非常负面的群体。例如，我的研究发现，在某些样本中，大约 20% 的人会说这样的话：无论风险多小、效益多大，培植肉都是错误的。因此，这也是一种对培植肉非常强烈、绝对的、几乎是道德上的反对，这在人口中所占的比例往往要小得多，但并非没有人。
It's interesting that there would be a moral objection because we already know how meat is currently produced, and it's not pretty. Whereas if we were to make meat in a lab, I mean, nobody has to die for this to happen. So where's the disconnect psychologically in people's brains? Why don't they see this? That's a really big question. And so while people can, generally people can see the environmental and animal welfare benefits of meat, of cultured meat over and above the way that factory farmed meat is produced,
存在道德反对意见这很有趣，因为我们已经知道肉类目前是如何生产的，而且并不美观。然而，如果我们要在实验室里制作肉类，我的意思是，没有人必须因此而死。那么人们大脑中的心理脱节在哪里？为什么他们看不到这一点？这是一个非常大的问题。虽然人们普遍能够看到培植肉在环境和动物福利方面优于工厂化养殖肉类的好处，
but there's sort of another element to the moral judgment that I think people are making, which ties into this notion of unnaturalness. And so often when you ask people, you know, what do you think about cultured meat? The negative things that come up, there's a whole range. But one that's very common is the idea that cultured meat is unnatural or disgusting, and these two things kind of play, like, ply in together. And I think that for some people, that moralization comes from that belief that culture meat is unnatural. So in qualitative type interviews, you hear people saying things like, we shouldn't be playing God, we shouldn't be creating franken meat.
但我觉得人们在做出的道德判断中还有另一个要素，这与“非天然”的概念交织在一起。所以，当你问人们“你对培植肉有什么看法”时，出现的负面看法五花八门。但其中非常普遍的一个观点是，培植肉是不自然的或令人恶心的，这两者某种程度上交织在了一起。我认为对某些人来说，这种道德化源于对培植肉不自然的信念。因此，在定性访谈中，你会听到人们说这样的话：我们不应该扮演上帝，我们不应该创造弗兰肯斯坦肉（franken meat）。
And so it feels like a violation of nature to create meat without an animal. And I think that's the moralized view. Dr. Rosenfeld, do you hear the same things? Yes. Yeah, I think that the moralized part is really largely due to that perception that it's a violation of like moral people. and just the natural order. I think a lot of that also can tie into religiosity and views about the natureness that God would prescribe to humans to follow a set of sacred principles and not violate the natural order.
因此，在没有动物的情况下制造肉感觉是对自然的违背。我认为这就是被道德化的观点。罗森菲尔德博士，你听到过同样的说法吗？是的。是的，我认为道德化的部分在很大程度上归因于那种认为这是对道德人民违背的看法。以及对自然秩序的违背。我认为这很大程度上也与宗教信仰以及上帝规定人类遵循一套神圣原则、不违背自然秩序的自然观联系在一起。
I also think that some of the moral part, maybe to a lesser degree, because this is less of a moral instinct and more of a higher level of moral reasoning is the, concerns about cultured meats and an industry around it displacing traditional agricultural workers and industries. And so economically, if cultured meat were to become very mainstream, there would be a change in the labor force of what jobs people are working in the agricultural sector. And so I'm not an economist. I don't know exactly how that would play out, but I know that consumers as just people have concerns about economically how that would play out, perhaps especially consumers who live in more rural conservative areas
我还认为，道德部分的某些方面——也许程度较轻，因为这较少是一种道德本能，更多的是更高水平的道德推理——是对培植肉及其相关产业会取代传统农业工人和产业的担忧。因此，从经济上讲，如果培植肉变得非常主流，农业领域的就业劳动岗位将会发生变化。因此，我不是经济学家，我不知道这具体会如何发展，但我知道消费者作为普通人，对这在经济上将如何发展存有担忧，尤其是居住在更偏远的保守地区的消费者，
where the economies and people that they know and care about have livelihoods attached to traditional meat production. And I'm not an economist either, but I think we've seen this happen many times, the fact that we don't have corner bookshops anymore because of Amazon or that taxi cab drivers have been displaced by Lyfts, an Uber, you know, the marketplace does change, but that's not to make a judgment here. You know, we recently did an episode with Dr. Paul Rosen from the University of Pennsylvania,
那里的经济以及他们认识和关心的人的生计都与传统肉类生产息息相关。我也不是经济学家，但我想我们已经多次看到这种情况发生，由于亚马逊的存在，我们不再有街角书店了，或者出租车司机被 Lyft 和 Uber 取代了，你知道，市场确实在发生变化，但这并不是要在这里做出评判。你知道，我们最近采访了宾夕法尼亚大学的保罗·罗森（Paul Rosen）博士，
who is one of the foremost experts on disgust. And meat is one of those things that many people just generally find disgusting. I mean, is that an overarching theme as you are talking to people about cultivated meat? Is it just a general feeling of disgust toward meat? that drives people to say, I don't want to try it. First of all, I loved the interview with Paul Rosen. It was wonderful. I don't think that we have a solid answer to that question. So my sense is that there might be kind of too,
他是研究恶心情绪的顶尖专家之一。肉类是许多人普遍觉得恶心的东西之一。我的意思是，当你们与人们谈论培养肉时，这是一个贯穿始终的主题吗？这仅仅是对肉类普遍存在的恶心感，驱使人们说“我不想尝试”吗？首先，我很喜欢对保罗·罗森的采访。那真是太棒了。我不认为我们对这个问题有确切的答案。所以我的感觉是，可能存在，
the concept of disgust is quite complicated. So you have things like your physical disgust, so, you know, something is spoiled or, you know, the physical side of disgust that we have in reaction to feces, to bad meat, things like that. But then there's also this element of moral disgust, and moral disgust is sort of more. or something that you kind of see with outrage,
恶心的概念相当复杂。所以你会有诸如身体上的恶心之类的事情，你知道，某样东西变质了，或者，你知道我们在对粪便、变质肉类等做出反应时产生的身体方面的恶心。但随后也有道德恶心的元素，而道德恶心在某种程度上更像是你在愤慨中看到的那种东西，
where people have done something that you think of is morally wrong, and you report feeling morally disgusted by them. I don't know if we have a good sense of where the cultured attitudes towards cultured meat that are around disgust would fall into the physical disgust or the more moral disgust. But perhaps I just don't know the work. Daniel, is there anything out there that I'm missing. Yeah, so what Maddie says is a great point. And with disgust, it's such a complicated emotion,
当人们做了你认为在道德上是错误的事情时，你报告说对他们感到道德上的恶心。我不知道我们是否对围绕恶心的培植肉态度究竟属于身体恶心还是更偏向道德恶心有一个清醒的认识。但也许我只是对这项研究不了解。丹尼尔，有什么我漏掉的相关研究吗？是的，麦迪所说的是一个极好的观点。对于恶心来说，这是一种如此复杂的情绪，
especially to study and measure because of the way we use the word. We use words to describe emotions and feelings, and there can be a disconnect between the semantics, the labeling, versus the actual embodiment or inner psychological phenomenon. So there is work that I've done that can speak to this question indirectly, where I found in some work that if you look at whether people are vegetarian, versus meat eaters. Interestingly, vegetarians are a lot more averse to try and cultured meat.
特别是在研究和测量方面，因为我们使用这个词的方式。我们用词语来描述情绪和感觉，语义、标签与实际体验或内心心理现象之间可能存在脱节。因此，我做过的一些研究可以间接地回答这个问题，我在一些研究中发现，如果你看看人们是素食主义者还是食肉动物。有趣的是，素食主义者对尝试培植肉要排斥得多。
You would think vegetarians might be like, this is great, this aligns with my values, and maybe you think that they miss meat and they want an alternative that's not made from animals. What I found was that vegetarians are a lot less interested in trying cultured meat compared to meat eaters. And in my work, I found that this is really due presumably to vegetarians being more disgusted by culture of meat. So vegetarians are a lot more grossed out by culture of meat than meat eaters. And that, to me, speaks a lot to more of the physical disgust explanation because vegetarians would have moral opposition to meat. And that would lead to moral disgust. meat eaters don't really have physical disgust at meat because they enjoy it and they like it and
你可能会认为素食主义者会觉得：太棒了，这符合我的价值观，也许你会认为他们想念肉，并想要一个不是由动物制成的替代品。我发现的是，与食肉动物相比，素食主义者对尝试培植肉的兴趣要小得多。在我的研究中，我发现这大概确实是因为素食主义者对培植肉感到更恶心。因此，素食主义者比食肉动物对培植肉感到更多的反感。在我看来，这很大程度上说明了更多的身体恶心解释，因为素食主义者会对肉类产生道德反对。而这会导致道德恶心。食肉动物对肉类并没有真正的身体恶心，因为他们享受它、喜欢它，
they eat it a lot. Vegetarians have a lot of them, a strong physical disgust toward meat, and that seems to be really aligning up with this finding that they're not interested in trying it. I think it's just because vegetarians, whether they're really motivated by animal rights and in their mind, the idea of just meat is this part of an animal and they can't get out of their head, or just that they haven't eaten meat in many years and they lose the taste for it and in their mind it's no longer a food object for whatever reason,
而且他们经常吃。素食主义者中有许多人对肉类有强烈的身体恶心，这似乎真的与他们对尝试不感兴趣这一发现相吻合。我认为这只是因为素食主义者，无论他们是否真的受到动物权利的激励，在他们心目中，肉的概念就是动物的一部分，他们无法把它从脑海中抹去，或者只是他们已经很多年不吃肉了，他们失去了对它的味觉，在他们心里它不再是一个食物对象，无论出于何种原因，
it seems to have that same meaning, whether it's conventional meat or cultured meat. To a lot of vegetarians, meat is just meat and they don't want to eat it. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season
它似乎都具有相同的含义，无论是传统肉类还是培植肉。对许多素食主义者来说，肉就是肉，他们不想吃。您的夏天现在开始，尽享家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日优惠。是时候用 Nextgrill 四 burner 燃气烤炉开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节尽情招待亲朋好友，
with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
只需 499 美元即可购买汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）West Grove 七件套户外餐饮桌椅组合。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受超低价格保证。售完即止，价格有效期限为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，特定条款适用。详情请参阅 Homedepot.com/pricematch。
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够让我们迷失方向。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. What is keeping cultured meat from being sold to consumers in the U.S. other than the handful of state laws that I mentioned earlier that are prohibiting it,
希尔顿特惠活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期待的住宿体验。当您想要省钱而非惊喜时。您住哪里至关重要。希尔顿，专为您驻留。除了我前面提到的少数禁止它的州法律之外，是什么阻碍了培植肉在美国向消费者出售？
is it that the producers are realizing that the public sentiment is not in their favor, or is it something else? So my understanding of this is relatively limited. But from what I do understand, there is a bit of an issue with scalability. So producing culture of meat is expensive. It's a very specific process that needs to be under the right condition. So I've heard about several different plants that were, know, there to be being built basically to produce cultured meat at scale.
是因为生产者意识到公众情绪对他们不利，还是其他原因？所以我对此的了解相对有限。但从我所了解的情况来看，可扩展性存在一些问题。因此，生产培植肉成本高昂。这是一个非常具体的流程，需要在合适的条件下进行。所以我听说过几家不同的工厂，你知道，它们基本上是为了大规模生产培植肉而建造的。
And a couple of times we've had claims from different companies that cultured meat will be on the shelves by next year, I think, like 2021, for example. And although there are some places, I think, in restaurants in the States where you can buy it, it doesn't seem like that that's really been delivered. And so my understanding is there are some issues with scalability and also price. At the moment, it's very expensive to produce. And so you're going to be selling at a loss, which isn't not an economist either, but it seems like not a very economically viable model.
而且我们有过好几次来自不同公司的声明，说培植肉将在明年摆上货架，我想，比如 2021 年。尽管在美国的一些地方，我想在餐馆里你可以买到它，但似乎并没有真正兑现。因此，据我了解，可扩展性以及价格都存在一些问题。目前，它的生产成本非常高。所以你将亏本销售，虽然我不是经济学家，但这似乎不是一个经济上非常可行的模式。
So that's my understanding. From my sense, there's not really a lot of concern about consumer attitudes that would prevent it from being produced because there is also a lot of support out there. And I think the people producing this really do care about the product and the benefits that it can bring to the world. So I don't think that consumer attitudes are what's getting in the way. Let's talk about those benefits. What are the upsides to cultured meat? I think the biggest upsides of cultured meat, because all of the upsides have. opposing viewpoints you could debate.
这就是我的理解。在我看来，并没有太多对消费者态度的担忧会阻止它被生产，因为外面也有很多支持。我认为生产这个产品的人确实关心这个产品以及它能给世界带来的好处。所以我不认为消费者态度是阻碍因素。让我们谈谈这些好处。培植肉有哪些好处？我认为培植肉最大的好处是，因为所有的好处都有。你可以争论的对立观点。
A lot of those are just philosophical and other ones can be answered with a lot of data and estimation. But one that I think is the clearest is just reducing animal suffering. So conventional meat takes a lot of animal slaughter to create. And culture of meat does not take a lot of animal slaughter. In fact, it wouldn't really take any animal slaughter. And so I would say the biggest benefit is reducing animal suffering and reducing animal slaughter. The other benefits, I do believe, can be quite debated as far as how it will be
其中很多只是哲学的，而另一些可以用大量的数据和估计来回答。但我认为最明显的一个就是减少动物痛苦。因此，传统肉类需要屠宰大量动物才能制造出来。而培植肉不需要屠宰大量动物。事实上，它真的不需要屠宰任何动物。所以我可以说最大的好处是减少动物痛苦和减少动物屠宰。至于其他好处，我相信关于它将如何被
produced in nuances. So one benefit is a better environmental impact. And conventional meat takes just so much water, land, and greenhouse gas emissions to create. And it's very damaging for the environment, the way we produce it. Theoretically, culture beat is incredibly more sustainable. It takes a lot fewer resources to produce. Now, I'm not an expert in the environmental science of it, but I have heard that, especially before scaling up production, it can be quite energy intensive to create smaller batch, culture meat. And so I'm not sure of the details of what exact energy is used in that, but I do know that it's not a surefire claim yet to say. It's incredibly more environmentally friendly. I think that it will be at a certain point, and it has
生产以及其中的细微差别，其实可以有很多争论。所以一个好处是更好的环境影响。传统肉类的制造需要消耗大量的水、土地和温室气体排放。而且我们生产它的方式对环境破坏很大。理论上，培植肉的可持续性要高得惊人。它生产所需的资源要少得多。现在，我不是这方面的环境科学专家，但我听说，特别是在扩大生产规模之前，制造小批量的培植肉可能会消耗大量能源。所以我对其中使用的确切能源细节不是很确定，但我确实知道，现在就说它在环境上极其友好还为时过早。我认为在某个特定时间点它会是的，而且它
the incredible potential to be a lot more environmentally friendly as a matter of scaling that up in a thoughtful way and knowing how to execute that. And then the third benefit could be that it could be healthier. So it is still meat. So whatever health benefits or detriments, conventional meat comes with close your meat will pretty much mirror those. It's the same chemically and physically for you. But a big difference is that it could be cleaner than conventional meat. So, conventional meat, you need a lot of antibiotics and pollutants that get into the environment that animals for months, years of their life, just like humans, are exposed to a lot of toxins and antibiotics and disease and accumulate this in their body. And then we consume that.
具有以深思熟虑的方式扩大规模并知道如何执行的前提下，拥有变得更加环保的巨大潜力。第三个好处是它可能更健康。所以它仍然是肉。因此，传统肉类带来的任何健康益处或弊端，培植肉几乎都会如实反映。它在化学和物理上对你来说都是一样的。但一个巨大的区别是它可能比传统肉类更清洁。所以，传统肉类需要大量抗生素和污染物进入环境，动物在生命的几个月、几年里，就像人类一样，接触到大量的毒素、抗生素和疾病，并在体内积聚这些物质。然后我们消费这些。
Culture of meat can be created in a much more sanitary, controlled environment. And so you could prevent the meat from being exposed to a lot of these pollutants. And that's, could on a grand scale have a big health benefit. And then another issue is that raising animals for livestock and for meat is a threat to pandemics and to creating these diseases that spread between animal to animal, animal to human and vice versa. So when we have billions of farmed animals to trillions just existing and breathing and interacting with each other and us, we are increasing the risk of future pandemics like COVID outbursting. And so cultured meat could be a good way to reduce that risk as well, to have zoonic diseases
培植肉可以在更卫生、受控的环境中制造。因此，你可以防止肉类接触到许多这些污染物。从宏观来看，这可以带来巨大的健康益处。另一个问题是，饲养动物作为牲畜和肉类是对大流行病以及在动物与动物、动物与人类之间传播的疾病的威胁。因此，当我们拥有数以十亿计的养殖动物，甚至数以万亿计的动物在生存、呼吸并与彼此及我们互动时，我们正在增加未来像新冠疫情爆发这样的大流行病的风险。因此，培植肉可能是降低这种风险的好方法，可以使人畜共患疾病
go on the dip. Right. And of course, we're dealing with a bird flu problem right now. So cultured meat could help obviate that kind of a problem. Well, Dr. Wilkes, I want to talk to you a little bit more about the moral values and people's attitudes. Do these attitudes vary by country or culture? His research looked into that question?
有所下降。没错。当然，我们现在正在应对禽流感问题。所以培植肉可以帮助消除这种问题。嗯，威尔克斯博士，我想跟您多聊聊关于道德价值观和人们态度的信息。这些态度是否因国家或文化而异？您的研究是否探讨过这个问题？
So there has been some cross-cultural work. I actually recently reviewed this. And if you look at there was a scoping review done, and most of this work is still, you know, US, UK, Netherlands-based. And so we can't make very strong claims, in my view, about cross-cultural attitudes. But there's been a few studies that have compared across countries. And for example, one study that I think included 10 different countries around Europe,
所以确实有一些跨文化的工作。我最近实际上对此进行了综述。如果你看一下，曾有人做过一项范围界定综述，而大部分这类工作仍然是，你知道的，以美国、英国、荷兰为基础的。因此在我看来，我们无法就跨文化态度做出非常强有力的声明。但有少数研究对不同国家进行了比较。例如，我认为有一项研究涵盖了欧洲 10 个不同的国家，
found that people in France tended to have more. negative attitudes. Some work is found, for example, that participants in China have more positive attitudes, but then other work has found more negative attitudes. So it seems to be variable, but because we've got so many different kinds of questions being asked in different context for the surveys, I don't think we can make a strong claim about which countries are pro or against cultured meat at this point. Given what we know about the psychological factors at play, what are some of the ways that consumers might be encouraged to try cultured meat? One thing that comes up for me a lot is if you think about the benefits, so Daniel mentioned the benefits of cultured meat before, and when you survey people, that's what consumers see as well. So they see that it's good for the environment, it's good for animals, it's good for, from a zoonosis standpoint. But a lot of these benefits that people see are kind of distal to them, so it's not something that's going to affect them day to day, whereas the things that are very relevant to them are things like how much it costs, how it tastes, whether it's healthy, whether it's safe. And so I think that we need to meet consumers where their values are. So,
发现法国人往往有更多的消极态度。例如，一些研究发现中国参与者的态度更为主动，但另一些研究却发现更消极的态度。所以这似乎是多变的，但由于我们在调查中针对不同背景提出了如此多不同类型的问题，我认为我们目前无法就哪些国家赞成或反对培植肉做出强有力的断言。鉴于我们对起作用的心理因素的了解，有什么方法可以鼓励消费者尝试培植肉呢？我经常想到的一点是，如果你考虑这些好处——所以丹尼尔之前提到了培植肉的好处，而当你对人们进行调查时，这也是消费者所看到的。所以他们看到它对环境有益、对动物有益、从人畜共患病的角度来看有益。但人们看到的许多这些好处对他们来说有点遥远，所以这不是会影响他们日常生活的事情，而与他们高度相关的事情是诸如它要花多少钱、它尝起来怎么样、它是否健康、它是否安全之类的事情。因此，我认为我们需要在消费者的价值观所在之处迎合他们。所以，
So while everybody does care about animal suffering in the environment to some degree, the thing that people are thinking about when they're in the supermarket is how much does this cost? How much does, like, what does this taste like? Is this going to be something that I can cook and I feel familiar with? And so if we can try to appeal to people at their level or in line with their own values or moral beliefs about cultured meat, I think that's going to be a more compelling way to get people on board than trying to just sort of tell them, well, it's good for the environment, it's good for animals, so they for you should care about this.
虽然每个人在某种程度上都在乎动物痛苦和环境，但人们在超市时脑子里想的是这要花多少钱？这尝起来像什么？这会是我能烹饪并且让我觉得熟悉的东西吗？因此，如果我们能尝试在他们的水平上，或者顺应他们自己对培植肉的价值观或道德信仰来吸引他们，我认为这将是一种比仅仅试图告诉他们“它对环境有益、对动物有益，所以你们应该在乎这个”更有说服力的方法，能让人们加入进来。
That's right. Matti raises some million points there. And I think an analogy that you just came to mind was like, why do people, at least in the U.S., eat so much fast food like McDonald's and Burger King? It's not because they're concerned about the ethics or the environment or the health. It's just price, taste, and convenience. And so I think that culture of meat, if it has a good price point and taste the same as conventional meat, those are two fundamentals that are non-negotiables for consumers. And then in addition to that, I think two other really big factors are, is it convenient and is it socially normal? So people don't want to go out of their way to prepare food that's difficult or not readily available down the street.
没错。马蒂在那里提出了很多中肯的观点。我刚刚想到的一个类比是，为什么人们（至少在美国）吃那么多麦当劳和汉堡王这样的快餐？这不是因为他们关心道德、环境或健康。这只是价格、味道和便利性。因此，我认为培植肉如果能有一个好的价格点并且尝起来和传统肉类一样，这两点是消费者不可妥协的基础。除此之外，我认为另外两个非常重要的因素是，它方便吗？它在社会上正常吗？所以人们不想费力去准备困难或在街头随手买不到的食物。
And it has to be convenient. It has to fit within their schedule and not take any extra work to get it into their diet compared to any other fast food or meal they might eat in a given day. And then it has to be socially normal in that people, are really swayed by the desire to conform and to do what their friends and family and co-workers do. And they really don't want to stand out from the crowd, especially with food. People really want to just do what other people do on a subconscious level. Because when something is socially normal, especially a kind of food you consume, what it's saying to our mind on a very basic level is that this food is safe, trustworthy, probably tastes good, probably won't kill
它必须是方便的。它必须符合他们的日程安排，与他们在给定的一天中可能吃的任何其他快餐或饭菜相比，不需要任何额外的劳动就能将其融入饮食中。然后，它必须在社会上是正常的，因为人们确实很容易受到顺从欲望以及做他们的朋友、家人和同事所做的事情的影响。他们真的不想在人群中脱颖而出，特别是在食物方面。人们在潜意识里真的只想做别人做的事。因为当某样东西在社会上是正常的，特别是你消费的一种食物时，它在非常基本的层面上向我们的大脑传达的信息是，这种食物是安全的、值得信赖的、可能味道很好、至少在未来几十年里不会杀死我
me or give me any disease in the coming decades at least. And I'll also gain some degree of acceptance and respect from my friends and family who seem to eating it like them. It's just a way to fit in with the group. And it's a good heuristic to know that this food is all right to eat. So it's got to make its way into society and not be seen as this different thing. There's a lot of debate going on right now about highly processed foods and people becoming more aware of how much processed food we do eat today. Is cultured meat, would it be considered a highly processed food in the same sense that most of us think of that term? So my understanding is that this is a big narrative that's being pushed by people who are opposing culture. So there's been quite a bit of pushback on the cultured and plant-based meat industry about this being
或给我带来任何疾病。而且我还会从那些似乎像他们一样吃它的朋友和家人那里获得某种程度的接纳和尊重。这只是一种融入群体的方式。这是一个很好的启发式方法，可以知道这种食物可以放心吃。所以它必须进入社会，而不能被视为一种不同的东西。目前有很多关于高度加工食品的争论，人们越来越意识到我们今天吃加工食品的量有多大。培植肉，它会被认为是我们大多数人思考这个词时的那种高度加工食品吗？据我了解，这是反对培植肉的人正在大力推动的一种说法。因此，对于培植肉和植物性肉类行业是
something that is ultra-processed. And to my knowledge, and I'm not an expert on what classifies something as ultra-processed, but cultured meat doesn't meet that standard. So I don't think so. Though whether or not people believe that it is ultra-processed is a different question, of course. Of course. How did you both become interested in studying this topic? I think you both came to it from somewhat different research backgrounds. Dr. Rosenfeld, maybe you want to take that one first. I originally got into studying psychology, just because I've both been very interested in and just how people think and behave and feel as humans. And that naturally was what drew me to studying psychology at a basic level.
超加工食品这一说法，已经有很多反弹。据我所知——我不是将某种东西归类为超加工食品的专家——但培植肉并不符合这一标准。所以我不这么认为。当然，人们是否相信它是超加工食品则是另一个问题。当然。你们俩是如何对研究这个话题感兴趣的？我想你们两个的切入点来自截然不同的研究背景。罗森菲尔德博士，也许你想先回答这个问题。我最初开始研究心理学，纯粹是因为我一直对人类如何思考、行事和感受非常感兴趣。这自然而然地将我吸引到基础心理学研究中。
And then separately from that, I've always been very interested in food and nutrition and health. And so about 10 years ago, I decided personally, while I was studying in my early stages of studying psychology, I decided to go vegan. And at first, I did not think this was a big deal. It was like, what I eat is what I eat. And who else cares besides me? It just affects me and my body. And so I went vegan.
除此之外，我一直对食物、营养和健康非常感兴趣。因此大约 10 年前，我个人决定，当我在研究心理学的早期阶段时，我决定吃纯素。起初，我认为这没什么大不了的。就像，我吃什么就是什么。除了我之外谁在乎呢？它只影响我和我的身体。所以我开始吃纯素了。
I was like to friends like, yeah, by the way, I'm vegan now, family. By the way, I'm vegan. I thought the conversation would go something like, hey, I'm vegan. Oh, cool, Dan. That's good for you. All right. Let's go out and hang out. And it went something more like, why are you vegan?
我像对朋友和家人说的那样：“顺便说一句，我现在吃纯素了。”我以为对话会是这样的：“哦，酷，丹。这对你挺好。好吧。让我们出去玩吧。”但情况更像是：“你为什么要吃纯素？”
What the heck? And it was this massive deal. And I suddenly had to defend why I eat the way I do. And it was really forced upon me to become this defining thing of who I was. It was like, he's the vegan now. And I had no intention of making this a part of my life at all. But society and the culture just told me every day, you are now different. And this is some significant thing about who you are that says something about your masculinity,
怎么回事？这是一件天大的事。我突然不得不为我为什么这样吃进行辩护。这确实强加给我，成为定义我是谁的一件标志性事情。就像，他现在是个纯素食者了。我根本没打算让这成为我生活的一部分。但社会和文化每天都在告诉我：你现在不同了。这是关于你是谁的一件重要事情，它说明了你的男子气概、
your moral beliefs, probably your political beliefs, and what kind of car you might drive and so many other stereotypes and stigmas that came with that. And so I was interested in taking my interest in psychology and my experiences of being vegan to say, what is going on here with the way people think about veganism? and vegetarianism and just meat as this thing that has such significance for who you are and what you believe in terms of whether you eat it or not. So that's how I got interested in studying the psychology of veganism and meat and then ultimately culture of meat and doing this kind of work.
你的道德信仰、可能还有你的政治信仰、你可能会开什么车，以及随之而来的许多其他刻板印象和污名。因此，我有兴趣将我对心理学的兴趣和吃纯素的体验结合起来，去探究：人们看待纯素食主义、
Dr. Wilkes, what about you? Slightly different path. So I was actually raised vegetarian. So my parents are vegetarian. I grew up as a vegetarian. And they gave me the choice when I was about 10. to continue to be or not, and I chose to be. And then it kind of wasn't a major part of my life. It was just something that had always been. But I'd always been very upset about the impact of factory
素食主义以及肉类作为一种对你是谁以及你对是否食用它的信仰具有如此重要意义的事物的看法，到底是怎么回事？这就是我如何对研究纯素食主义和肉类的心理学，并最终研究培植肉并从事这类工作感兴趣的起因。威尔克斯博士，你呢？稍微不同的路径。所以我其实是由素食主义父母抚养长大的。所以我的父母是素食主义者，我是在素食环境中长大的。在我大约 10 岁的时候，他们给了我选择，
farming. It was something I'd always really cared about. In a completely separate part of my life, I'd started studying psychology, and I was actually working on kind of social learning in children and chimpanzees. So I was working on human and animal cognition, how do humans differ from other animals? And then I went into a PhD starting to work on children's moral judgments. So it was a sort of a slow progressed. I was interested in morality and human animal interactions and things like that. And around about a year or so before I started my PhD, I remember reading about, you know, cultured meat being unveiled in London. It was this big thing. And I thought to myself, wow, this is the first thing I can see, which actually could help everybody to give up factory
农业。这是我一直非常关心的事。在我生活的另一个完全不同的领域，我开始学习心理学，实际上我当时正在研究儿童和黑猩猩的社会学习。所以我当时从事的是人类和动物的认知研究，人类与其他动物有什么不同？然后我攻读博士学位，开始研究儿童的道德判断。所以这是一个缓慢进展的过程。我对道德、人与动物的互动以及诸如此类的事情很感兴趣。大约在我开始攻读博士学位前一年左右，我记得读到关于在伦敦亮相的培育肉的新闻。这是一件大事。当时我想，哇，这是我看到的能够真正帮助所有人放弃工厂的
farmed meat, because I had kind of come to the conclusion that you probably weren't going to convince everybody to stop eating meat. And so I thought this was extremely cool. And I spent about two or three years asking everybody I knew, like, would you eat cultured meat and just being, you know, quite obnoxious about it really. And then during my PhD, it occurred to me, like, I'm a scientist and I'm a psychologist. I can actually do research on this. And so I just sat out and was like, I'm going to try and do some work. And there was no psychological research on it at the time. So it was quite a scary undertaking, but I'm really glad I did. I'm just wondering, I know, Dr. Rosenfeld, you've looked at gender differences in meat
农场肉类的第一件事，因为我当时得出结论，你大概无法说服所有人停止吃肉。所以我认为这非常酷。我花了两三年时间问我认识的每个人，比如，你会吃培育肉吗，而且表现得真的挺讨人厌的。然后在我的博士期间，我突然意识到，我是一名科学家，也是一名心理学家。我实际上可以对此进行研究。于是我开始着手去做，心想我要尝试做一些工作。当时这方面没有任何心理学研究，所以这是一个相当可怕的尝试，但我真的很高兴我这么做了。我只是在想，罗森费尔德博士，我知道你研究过肉类的性别差异
consumptions and as you've looked at attitudes toward eating. I'm just wondering what you have found. So there's a long history of gender in being related to just our agricultural system and the foods that we eat, and I think of all the foods meat might be the most gendered of all the foods. And what I found there basically is a couple of findings that just summarize the work. One is that men just seem to like meat more than women. And the idea of giving up meat is a lot scarier and more daunting to men than women.
消费，而且你也研究过对饮食的态度。我很想知道你发现了什么。因此，性别与我们的农业系统以及我们所吃的食物之间有着长期的历史联系，我认为在所有的食物中，肉类可能是最具性别色彩的食物。我基本上发现了一些能够总结这项研究的结论。一是男人似乎比女人更喜欢吃肉。而且对男人来说，放弃肉类比对女人来说要可怕和令人生畏得多。
And men eat more meat. They eat more frequently and they eat larger servings of meat. And this holds true for all kinds of meat. It holds true for beef, for pork, for chicken, for fish. So across the board, men just like meat more than women. And there's also a attitude that men hold toward meat that really aligned with this is that men don't think meat is as bad for the environment as women do. Men think meat is healthier than women. And also, if you ask men and women, they will say that they do associate meat with masculinity and manhood.
而且男人吃更多的肉。他们吃得更频繁，分量也更大。各种肉类都是如此。牛肉、猪肉、鸡肉、鱼肉都是如此。因此总的来说，男人就是比女人更喜欢肉。男人对肉类还有一种态度与之高度吻合，那就是男人认为肉类对环境的危害没有女人认为的那么大。男人认为肉类比女人认为的更健康。而且，如果你问男人和女人，他们会说他们确实把肉类与男子气概和男性身份联系在一起。
And the idea of a man not eating meat seems to just irritate people. It's more of a gender role violation from what you expect. It seems to just irritate people more than the idea of a woman not eating meat. And so those are the main findings I found here. Just this link between meats and masculinity that crickles down into people's behaviors and thoughts and desires and concerns and fears. So what's next for you both? Dr. Wilkes, what are you working on and you're still deep in the whole cultured meat research?
男人不吃肉的想法似乎只会让人感到烦恼。这比人们预期的更多地违反了性别角色。与女人不吃肉的想法相比，这似乎更让人烦恼。这些就是我在研究中发现的主要结论。正是这种肉类与男子气概之间的联系，渗透到了人们的行为、思想、欲望和担忧与恐惧之中。那么，你们两个接下来有什么打算？威尔克斯博士，你在研究什么？你是否仍然深耕于培育肉的研究？
Yeah, so I'm still doing a bit of work on cultured meat. My most recent work has been looking at things like the moral foundations that underpin people's attitudes. So we did some work where we found that – so if you look at the narrative around cultured meat, it's all about harm reduction, which is what we were talking about before. It's good for the environment, good for animals, things like that. So we expected that people who cared more about harm would have more positive attitudes to cultured meat. And people who cared more about purity would have more negative attitude. And we found evidence to support the second thing.
是的，所以我仍然在做一些关于培育肉的工作。我最近的工作一直在研究诸如支撑人们态度的道德基础之类的事情。所以我们做了一些研究发现——如果你看看围绕培育肉的叙事，它完全是关于减少伤害的，也就是我们之前谈到的。它对环境有益，对动物有因此，我们曾预计，更关心伤害的人对培育肉会有更积极的态度。而更关心纯洁性的人会有更消极的态度。我们找到了支持第二种观点的证据。
So people who have high purity concerns are more likely to oppose cultured meat. But we found no link between people's attitudes towards harm and how they feel about cultured meat, which was really surprising. And we've done this across a couple of samples. So I'm interested in trying to extend that a little bit further, understand more about the kind of moral values that underpin people's attitudes. But I also do, so as you mentioned, I work across a whole range of topics. So I'm really interested in this idea of the moral circle.
因此，对纯洁性有很高顾虑的人更有可能反对培育肉。但我们发现人们对伤害的态度与他们对培育肉的看法之间没有任何联系，这真的很令人惊讶。我们在几个样本中都验证了这一点。所以我希望能把这一点再推进一步，更多地了解支撑人们态度的道德价值观。但我也做——正如你所提到的，我的研究涵盖了广泛的主题。所以我对道德圈这个概念非常感兴趣。
So that is a way to describe who we do and don't. think of as worthy of moral concern. Beings that are closer to the center of your moral circle are granted more moral concern and those are closer to the edges are granted less. And this concept's been around in philosophy for a long time but more recently we've seen a lot of psychological work trying to describe and understand our moral circles. And I'm really interested in sort of understanding individual variability here, so why some people care really widely about a whole range of different beings and some people care in a more contracted way so they focus their energy on their friends and family. And I'm particularly
这是一种用来描述我们认为谁值得或不值得进行道德关怀的方式。离你的道德圈中心更近的生物会被给予更多的道德关怀，而离边缘更近的生物得到的则较少。这个概念在哲学中存在了很长时间，但最近我们看到许多心理学研究试图描述和理解我们的道德圈。我真的很想了解这里的个体差异，即为什么有些人对各种各样的生物给予广泛的关怀，而有些人则以更收缩的方式关怀，他们把精力集中在朋友和家人身上。我特别
interested in the moral concern that we feel for distant beings. So why do some people care about animals or people in other countries who live far away or potentially nature and the environment, things like that? So understanding what drives people to care about these distant others is something that I'm really excited to explore. And I'm also doing a little bit of work trying to understand what we actually mean when we talk about moral concern. So it's easy to say, you know, do you feel moral concern for a person or a pig or, you know, all these different categories? But what do we actually mean when we're talking about moral concern? What sentiment are we capturing there?
对我们对遥远生物感到的道德关怀感兴趣。那么，为什么有些人关心动物、其他国家生活在远方的人，或者潜在的自然和环境等等？因此，理解是什么驱使人们关心这些遥远的他人是我非常兴奋去探索的事情。我也在做一些工作，试图理解当我们谈论道德关怀时，我们实际上指的是什么。所以说起来容易，你知道的，你对一个人、一头猪或所有这些不同的类别感到道德关怀吗？但当我们谈论道德关怀时，我们究竟是什么意思？我们在其中捕捉到什么情感？
Dr. Rosenfeld, what's up for you? So at that is heart, I like food psychology and thinking about people's eating behaviors. And so I am interested in how people think about culture of meat compared to other comparable novelty or outlier foods categories that also have benefits, whether it's for health or the environment or animals. So one analogy would be things like eating at a farmer's market or eating local or eating organic or avoiding GMO. There are just a lot of other examples throughout history and now where we've seen these movements evolve and become more normalized or not. And just understanding like what are the parallels between culture meat and these other movements? But then also what are the differences?
罗森费尔德博士，你最近在忙什么？本质上，我喜欢食物心理学，喜欢思考人们的饮食行为。因此，我有兴趣了解人们如何看待培育肉，与其他具有类似创新性或非主流特点、同样具有健康、环境或动物福利等益处的食物类别相比，情况如何。一个类比就是在农贸市场吃饭、吃当地食物、吃有机食物或避免转基因。历史上和现在都有很多其他的例子，我们看到这些运动发展并变得更加规范化或没有规范化。我想了解培育肉与这些其他运动之间的相似之处是什么？但同时也有哪些不同之处？
Dr. Wilkes, Dr. Wollks, Dr. Rosenfeld, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening.
威尔克斯博士，沃克斯博士，罗森费尔德博士，感谢你们今天加入我。非常感谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingof psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学对话》由莉·韦纳曼制作。感谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学协会。在拉尔夫斯超市享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有低价。当您下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，您可以每周通过数字优惠券裁剪并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取积分，在加油时每加仑最多节省 1 美元。在拉尔夫斯，您每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过节省和奖励，每天都可以轻松省大钱。拉尔夫斯南加州分店已超过 150 年。节省金额可能因州而异。加油限制适用。详情请参见网站。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。